Wenn euch Bürger etwas wert sind,
dann lasst ihr das Spital offen!
Spitalschliessungen
wecken Widerstand.
Aber sie sind unausweichlich,
sagen Experten und Politikerinnen.
Bei rund jedem zehnten Spital
ist es sogar relativ prekär.
Es wird in den nächsten Jahren
zu Schliessungen
und zu Umwandlungen
in neue ambulante Strukturen kommen.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass kleine
Spitäler keine Zukunft mehr haben.
Die betroffenen Regionen
fühlen sich im Stich gelassen.
Die Gefahr ist, dass
die Städte immer stärker werden,
dass das Land
letztlich unattraktiver wird.
Ich habe Angst.
- Sie haben Angst? Oje.
Wenn ein Spital schliesst,
machen sich viele Menschen Sorgen.
Wenn jemand einen Hirnschlag,
eine Hirnblutung
oder einen Herzstillstand hat,
hat er von hier hinten
bis nach dort vorne
vielleicht eine Chance
von etwa 20 %.
Stimmt das wirklich?
Und könnten die über 200 Schweizer
Spitäler auch in Zukunft bestehen?
Das ist finanziell nicht tragbar,
und v.a. findet man
auch das Personal nicht.
Selbst mit einem Gönner
könnte qualifiziertes Personal
nicht in jedem Dorf
organisiert werden.
Wären weniger Spitäler sogar besser
für Patientinnen und Patienten?
Die Versorgung wird anders,
vernetzter, grossräumiger
und dann sogar besser als vorher.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Das Spital Laufen muss schliessen.
Heute werden die letzten
Patientinnen und Patienten
in ein anderes Spital verlegt.
Ich begreife,
dass man diese Ballungszentren hat
für wirklich Schwerverletzte
und Schwerkranke.
Aber dass man so ein Regionalspital
einfach schliesst,
wo man sich dort
doch so wohlfühlt ...
150 Jahre lang hat das Spital Laufen
Menschen behandelt.
Diese Tradition endet heute.
Die Geräte werden
in die anderen beiden Spitäler
des Kantons Baselland gebracht.
Die Pflegefachleute
werden anders eingeteilt.
Für mich persönlich
ist das natürlich nicht so schön.
Ich bin seit fast 30 Jahren
hier im Haus.
Ich habe auch Herzblut
in diesem Haus.
Für die Patienten tut es mir leid,
auch für diejenigen im Tal,
die nicht mehr hierherkommen können.
Dieses Haus wird fehlen,
das ist klar.
Norbert Schnitzler, Chef
aller Baselbieter Kantonsspitäler,
setzt die Schliessung
des Spitals Laufen um.
Medizin kann immer mehr und
kann immer mehr in die Tiefe gehen,
ist also wirklich
sehr spezialisiert.
Für ein kleines Haus
ist es immer schwieriger,
die Breite dieser Medizin
abzudecken.
Deshalb kommt man in einen Konflikt.
Will man ein gutes Angebot,
bei dem man weiss,
dass man da gut versorgt ist?
Oder wollen und müssen wir wirklich
den letzten Stand der Medizin
anbieten?
Laufen ist kein Einzelfall,
sondern steht für
eine schweizweite Entwicklung.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
V.a. Regionalspitäler
kommen unter Druck.
Praktisch in allen Kantonen
sind Spitalschliessungen ein Thema,
egal, ob in ländlichen
oder städtischen Regionen.
Vielerorts gibt es konkrete Pläne
für weitere Schliessungen.
Wenn ein Spital geschlossen wird,
trifft das die ganze Region,
etwa das Laufental.
Was fehlt den Menschen,
wenn das Spital nicht mehr da ist?
Sommer 2020 - wenige Monate, bevor
das Spital Laufen geschlossen wird.
Einsatz
bei einer 87-jährigen Patientin.
Guten Tag, Rettungsdienst.
- Guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
- Barth ist mein Name.
Barth?
Wie der Schnauz, aber Barth.
Wie geht's Ihnen, Frau Baur?
Nicht gut.
- Was ist passiert?
Ich kann nicht aufstehen.
- Sie können nicht aufstehen.
Die Frau wohnt allein zu Hause,
unterstützt von der Spitex.
Nun muss sie ins Spital
für weitere Abklärungen.
In welchem Spital
werden Sie behandelt, Frau Baur?
In Laufen.
- Im Spital Laufen.
Wir rufen an und fragen,
ob das in Laufen möglich ist.
Sonst müssen wir
Alternativen zu Laufen suchen.
Aha.
- Wäre das auch in Ihrem Sinn?
Ich möchte schon lieber
in Laufen sein. Daheim ist daheim.
Natürlich.
- Hier ist Dani vom Rettungsdienst.
Sie wird allenfalls stationär.
Kommen wir zu euch oder müssen wir
ein anderes Spital anfahren?
Du meinst also, es geht nicht?
Okay, na dann. Tschau.
Also, wir können grundsätzlich in
Laufen eine Erstuntersuchung machen.
Wenn Sie aber für ein paar Tage
im Spital bleiben müssen,
dann müssen Sie in
ein anderes Spital verlegt werden.
Möchten Sie ins Bruderholzspital
oder nach Dornach?
Das sind die nächsten zwei Spitäler.
- Ich möchte lieber nach Laufen.
Sonst kann mich niemand besuchen
und ich kenne niemanden.
Das ist für Sie auch mehr Stress.
Wenn wir nach Laufen gehen,
und der Doktor sagt: "Bleiben",
müssten Sie in ein anderes
Spital gehen, um zu übernachten.
Ich habe es schon verstanden.
Das Risiko ist Ihnen bewusst und
Sie möchten trotzdem nach Laufen?
Ja.
- Dann machen wir das so.
Doch ist das sinnvoll? Die Spitex-
Mitarbeiterin hat kein gutes Gefühl.
Gehen Sie doch direkt nach Dornach.
Dornach ist 20 Min. von hier.
Ja.
- Hm?
* Frau Baur stöhnt. *
Ärgerlich, was?
- (Barth) Oje.
Tja. Sie meinen,
ich sollte nach Dornach gehen?
Ja.
- Na dann.
Wenn Sie mir das empfehlen ...
- Ja, ja, das finde ich besser.
* Dynamische Xylofonmusik *
Die Rettungssanitäter fahren
die Patientin von zu Hause weg,
weg von Laufen.
Bis zum Spital Dornach sind es
rund 16 km, 20 Min. Autofahrt.
Ich habe Angst.
- Sie haben Angst?
Oje.
Viele Fragen tauchen auf.
Kann ich wieder nach Hause gehen
oder muss ich ins Altersheim?
Werde ich überhaupt wieder gesund?
In solchen Situationen möchten
viele Patientinnen und Patienten
möglichst nahe
bei ihrem Zuhause sein.
Ich finde es natürlich schade.
Die Patientin will in Laufen,
in ihrer Umgebung bleiben.
Hier ist sie in guten Händen,
aber mir tut es für sie leid.
Sie ist weiter weg von zu Hause.
Es ist schwieriger,
denn sie kann nicht ÖV fahren
und ist auf Liegend- oder
Sitzendtransport angewiesen.
Das tut mir persönlich schon ...
Ich finde es nicht witzig.
Also, alles Gute. Machen Sie's gut.
Adieu.
- (Frau) Ah, super.
(Mann) Vielleicht reicht das.
- Tschüss.
Viele Regionalspitäler
sind unter Druck.
Ein Grund: Ihnen geht das Geld aus.
Philip Sommer weiss, warum. Er ist
Gesundheitsökonom und berät Spitäler.
Seit Jahren analysiert er
die Finanzen der Branche.
Für viele Spitäler
geht die Rechnung nicht mehr auf.
Vieles in der Medizin wird teurer,
doch die Patienteneinnahmen
bleiben gleich oder sinken sogar.
Deutlich mehr als
die Hälfte der Schweizer Spitäler,
also der Grossteil der Schweizer
Spitäler, verdient zu wenig,
um eigene Investitionen
zahlen zu können.
Bei rund jedem zehnten Spital
ist es sogar relativ prekär.
Dort reichen die Eigenmittel,
also das verfügbare Kapital
eines Spitals,
nur noch wenige Jahre,
um die Verluste zu decken.
In solchen Fällen
muss dann entweder der Eigentümer
mit Steuergeldern retten,
oder man schaut aktiv, wie man
die Strukturen anpassen kann.
Es wird in den nächsten Jahren
zu Schliessungen und Umwandlungen
in ambulante Strukturen kommen.
Strukturwandel - hier
im St. Galler Rheintal heisst das:
Das Spital Altstätten
soll geschlossen werden.
Noch führen Chirurgen
hier einfache Eingriffe durch.
Das schätzen viele Menschen
in der Region.
* Wabernde Orgelmusik *
Auch in den Hügeln
oberhalb des Rheintals.
Hier wohnt Walter Frei,
ein passionierter Mofa-Restaurateur.
Frei muss Gallensteine
samt Gallenblase entfernen lassen.
Für die Operation möchte er ins
Regionalspital in Altstätten gehen.
Ich bin froh,
dass es für mich so nah ist.
Das ist immerhin noch persönlich.
Weil es halt im Rheintal ist.
Ob ein Arzt oder ein Privater,
man ist schnell per Du.
Das finde ich schon sehr wichtig.
Die Beziehung ist ganz anders.
Man sieht ihn
nicht wie einen Arzt an,
sondern eher wie einen Bekannten.
Er erzählt es mir ganz anders.
"Weisst du, es ist so und so."
"Du musst keine Angst haben."
Tag der Operation, 6 Uhr morgens.
Walter Frei
ist einer von rund 2'000 Patienten,
die in Altstätten
pro Jahr operiert werden.
Es ist ja nicht nur meinetwegen,
dass das Spital Altstätten
bleiben sollte.
Es geht ja um die ganze Region.
Die Wege
werden nachher für alle viel länger.
Bis ins Spital Altstätten
sind es für ihn nur 10 km.
Kaum losgefahren,
sind wir schon fast da.
Was anders nicht so wäre,
dann müssten wir
noch fast 30 Min. fahren.
Geht es für Sie mit dem Koffer?
- Ist gut, ja.
Walter Frei schätzt die familiäre
Stimmung im Regionalspital.
Er mag es, wenn ihm
auf Augenhöhe begegnet wird.
Und er mag seine Region.
Dennoch muss das Spital Altstätten
wahrscheinlich schliessen -
gleichzeitig mit mehreren Spitälern
im Kanton St. Gallen.
Die Regierung plant eine Radikalkur.
Von den neun öffentlichen Spitälern
sollen fünf geschlossen werden.
Übrig bliebe ein Gesundheitszentrum,
eine Art Gemeinschaftspraxis
mit einfacher Notfallstation.
Betroffen sind Altstätten,
Rorschach, Flawil und Wattwil.
Der Entscheid zu Walenstadt
wird aufgeschoben.
Für die betroffenen Regionen
geht es um mehr als das Spital.
Das Städtchen Altstätten
zählt 12'000 Einwohner.
Wenn das Spital weg ist,
verliert der Ort an Attraktivität,
befürchtet Stadtpräsident
Ruedi Mattle.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Morgen.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Es ist Herbst 2020 -
mitten in der politischen Debatte
um die Spitalschliessungen.
Wünsche dir ein schönes Wochenende.
- Danke. Tschau.
Der Kanton will
weniger Regionalspitäler betreiben.
Doch Mattle
will sein Spital behalten.
Den Bund auch?
- Nein, gerne entfernen.
Einerseits geht es um eine wohnort-
nahe Grund- und Notfallversorgung,
aber es geht auch darüber hinaus.
Es ist
ein wichtiger Wirtschaftsfaktor.
Das Spital ist einer der grössten
Arbeitgeber hier in Altstätten.
Und wir haben eine Wertschöpfung.
Das Spital kauft Brot beim Bäcker
und auch anderes in der Region.
Die ganze Wertschöpfung
in Altstätten und der Region
ginge verloren,
wenn das Spital nicht mehr da wäre.
Und fünf rote Zwiebeln.
- Gerne.
Die Menschen beschäftigt,
dass sie künftig nicht mehr im
eigenen Städtchen ins Spital können.
Wenn man etwas Schwerwiegendes hat,
muss man nach St. Gallen gehen.
Logisch, das musste ich auch tun.
Sie waren sehr freundlich,
aber es ist ein weiter Weg.
Und es ist ein Moloch.
Schönes Wochenende.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Auf Wiedersehen.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Regierungspräsident Bruno Damann
unterwegs zur entscheidenden
Kantonsratsdebatte im September 2020.
Heute ist ein wichtiger Tag -
nicht für mich selbst,
sondern für
den ganzen Kanton St. Gallen -
damit wir in der Spitalplanung
vorankommen
und eine gute
Gesundheitsversorgung haben.
Im Sommer haben ihm
seine Regierungskollegen
die Aufgabe übertragen,
die Spitalstrategie
politisch durchzubringen.
Ein heisses Eisen - Spitäler
zu schliessen, ist unpopulär.
Einem Regierungsrat, der sich
dafür einsetzt, droht die Abwahl.
Damann
scheint der richtige Mann zu sein.
Er tritt bei der nächsten Wahl
altersbedingt
vermutlich nicht mehr an.
Und der Mitte-Politiker hat als Arzt
in medizinischen Fragen
besondere Glaubwürdigkeit.
Doch wieso will ein Arzt
gleich mehrere Spitäler schliessen?
Es geht um die Qualität,
nicht unbedingt nur um die Finanzen.
Qualität wird in kleinen Spitälern
immer schwieriger zu gewährleisten.
Wir haben zu wenige Fachpersonen,
wir haben zu wenige Ärzte,
aber auch zu wenig Pflegende, die
noch in kleinen Spitälern arbeiten.
Und darum ist es nötig, dass wir
die ganze Spitalstrategie umbauen.
So wird er
den ganzen Tag argumentieren.
Ich hoffe, dass die Zeit reif ist,
dass man jetzt auch spürt,
dass Distanzen
kein so wichtiger Punkt mehr sind.
Morgen, Bruno.
- Hallo, Andreas.
Auch ein Parteikollege
aus dem Kantonsrat reist an.
Seit über 20 Jahren wird im Kanton
über die Spitäler gestritten -
immer gehen die Emotionen hoch.
Es soll eine kleine Demo geben.
Ich bin gespannt, wie viele kommen.
Ja, darum bin ich früh unterwegs,
damit ich
nicht an ihnen vorbeigehen muss.
Zu reden gibt die Spitalstrategie
auch, weil sie eine Kehrtwende ist.
2014 gab es
ein wuchtiges Ja zu den Spitälern.
Das St. Galler Stimmvolk bewilligte
Kredite im Umfang von 930 Mio. Fr.
für Neubauten und Sanierungen.
Es war auch ein Ja
zu den Regionalspitälern.
In Wattwil
wurde daraufhin neu gebaut,
doch bereits bei der Einweihung
war von Schliessung die Rede.
Das Hin und Her
ist für viele unverständlich.
Der Gesundheitsökonom
beobachtet in der ganzen Schweiz,
dass Spitäler zuerst ausbauen,
um im Wettkampf zu bestehen,
ihnen dann aber das Geld ausgeht.
Die Absicht war eigentlich,
dass im Wettbewerb
unter den Spitälern
die erfolgreichen
nachhaltig überleben
und sich die anderen Strukturen
konsolidieren,
also mit der Zeit wegfallen.
Und ich glaube, das kommt jetzt.
Es war ein mehrjähriger Prozess.
Am Anfang wurde aufgerüstet,
aber jetzt beginnen die positiven
Vorteile des Wettbewerbs zu spielen.
Wir sehen jetzt, dass der Umbruch,
diese Konsolidierung,
sprich: weniger Spitäler,
jetzt eintrifft.
(Durchsage) St. Gallen,
Ihre nächsten Verbindungen ...
Den Widerstand der Bevölkerung
gegen die Spitalschliessungen
bekommen
die Politiker/-innen zu spüren.
Auch heute
vor der Olma-Halle in St. Gallen,
wo der Kantonsrat wegen Corona tagt.
Ihr könnt nicht einfach
Spitäler schliessen.
Wir sind darauf angewiesen.
Wenn euch Bürger etwas wert sind,
dann lasst ihr das Spital offen.
Wir können nicht alle
in die Städte verwiesen werden.
Wir sind darauf angewiesen.
Wir können nicht nur ...
Wir müssen ...
Wenn ein Spital in der Nähe ist,
lassen sich bei uns
auch Hausärzte nieder.
So haben wir
angemessene Wege ins Spital.
Ruedi Mattle,
Stadtpräsident von Altstätten,
sitzt im Kantonsrat
in der Fraktion der Grünliberalen.
Er tritt an, um sein Spital
in Altstätten zu retten.
Es zeigt: Das Thema bewegt -
v.a. in den ländlichen Regionen.
Und es zeigt, dass die Debatte heute
sehr wichtig ist.
Wir treffen heute Vorentscheide,
die langfristig wirken werden.
Schon vor der Debatte
zeichnet sich ab,
dass mehr Parteien als erwartet
die Spitalschliessungen unterstützen.
Aber es gibt auch
erbitterten Widerstand.
Es wird eine harte Diskussion
und ein langer Sessionstag.
Regierungsrat Damann
greift immer wieder ein,
um den Rat
auf seine Linie zu bringen.
Wir müssen die Qualität
auch in der Zukunft sicherstellen.
Wir könnten die Augen verschliessen
und künftig Millionen
an unsere Spitäler überweisen,
aber damit
wäre das Problem nicht gelöst.
Wir müssen jetzt endlich
Nägel mit Köpfen machen.
In der Debatte geht es um Geld,
Qualität und Regionen,
die sich im Stich gelassen fühlen.
Akutspitäler in den Regionen sind
nicht einfach nur Kostentreiber.
Sie sind lebenswichtig -
nicht nur für die Menschen dort,
sondern auch für die Gemeinden,
die lokale Wirtschaft,
die Zulieferer, die Lieferanten,
die niedergelassenen Ärzte
und die Arbeitnehmer/-innen.
Die Spitalschliessungen
werden für die betroffenen Regionen
verheerend sein.
Es ist aus finanziellen Überlegungen
nicht möglich,
in allen Regionen
Mehrspartenspitäler zu betreiben.
Die Bevölkerung wird immer älter,
darum sind
die Patientinnen und Patienten
und insbesondere auch ihre Ange-
hörigen auf kurze Wege angewiesen.
Durch die Entwicklung der Medizin
entsprechen die bisherigen,
dezentralen Landspitäler
nicht mehr
den heutigen Anforderungen.
Es muss manchmal,
so leid es mir tut,
auch etwas sterben,
damit etwas Neues entstehen kann.
Die Politik diskutiert über
die Zukunft der Regionalspitäler ...
... während im Regionalspital
Altstätten noch operiert wird.
* Stakkatoartige Musik *
Guten Morgen.
- Morgen miteinander.
Walter Frei wird jetzt
die Gallenblase entfernt.
Ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute.
- Danke sehr. Okay, merci.
In dieser Umgebung kann sich
Walter Frei gut entspannen.
Für die Narkose soll er sich
einen angenehmen Traum überlegen.
Wohin die Reise geht,
entscheiden Sie.
Wir passen gut auf Sie auf.
- Das ist super.
Ich fühle mich gut aufgehoben.
Nicht mehr nervös. Nichts.
Alles weg.
Gallenblasenoperationen
gehören zu den Eingriffen,
die in Altstätten
noch durchgeführt werden.
Für den Chirurgen ist klar:
Dafür braucht man
nicht unbedingt ein grosses Spital.
Es ist ein Routineeingriff,
auch für mich.
Das ist sozusagen das Handwerkszeug
des Allgemeinchirurgen.
Das ist eine
der häufigsten Operationen
in der Allgemeinchirurgie.
Heute haben wir noch mal
eine Gallenblase zu operieren.
Können Sie die Operation
hier in Altstätten gut machen?
Ja, weil wir
die entsprechende Logistik haben.
Das Spital Altstätten habe alles,
was man brauche,
um diese Operation
gut und sicher durchzuführen.
* Regelmässige Pieptöne *
Nach knapp 1 Std. sind Gallenblase
und Gallensteine draussen.
Die Operation ist gut gegangen,
auch wenn es
etwas schwieriger war als gedacht.
Bleiben Sie noch liegen, ja?
- Hallo.
Es war allerdings
ein kleines bisschen komplizierter,
Anzeichen der chronischen Entzündung
waren doch deutlich sichtbar.
Aber wir haben 1 Std. gebraucht,
was auch so geplant war.
Und das Ergebnis ist so,
wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Trotzdem sollen
Patienten wie Walter Frei
in Zukunft nicht mehr
in Altstätten operiert werden.
Die drohende Schliessung beschäftigt
auch die Mitarbeiter/-innen.
Ich hoffe, dass es erhalten bleibt.
Für kleine und mittlere
Eingriffe ist es das ideale Spital.
Man muss nicht lange warten, und
wir haben hier geniale Operateure.
Ich denke, das zählt.
Es ist alles gut gegangen.
Wie ist es mit Schmerzen?
- Gut.
Keine? Sehr gut.
Erleichtert.
Ich bin froh, dass es vorbei ist.
Im Kantonsparlament stehen
die entscheidenden Abstimmungen
zu den Regionalspitälern bevor.
Ruedi Mattles letzter Trumpf:
Das Spital Altstätten in ein Zentrum
für Altersmedizin umzufunktionieren
und es so zu retten.
Sehr geehrter Herr
Kantonsratspräsident,
geschätzte Mitglieder beider Räte,
Qualität kann darf man nicht nur
anhand von Fallzahlen messen.
Qualität ist
gerade für ältere Menschen
z.B. auch
eine wohnortsnahe Grundversorgung,
der Zugang zu Bezugspersonen
und lokalen Institutionen
oder überschaubare Strukturen.
Der Regierungsrat kontert:
Bei älteren Menschen
drohten oft Komplikationen.
Damit seien Regionalspitäler
überfordert
und die Patientinnen und Patienten
müssten in einem grossen Spital
weiterbehandelt werden.
Je älter ein Patient
oder eine Patientin ist,
desto mehr
müssen Verlegungen vermieden werden.
Einen solchen Weg
für die Zukunft einzuschlagen,
ist für mich
schlicht unverantwortlich.
Mattles Antrag wird von der SP
und einzelnen Politikern anderer
Parteien unterstützt. Reicht das?
(Mann) Wir stimmen jetzt ab.
* Stakkatoartige Musik *
Der Antrag zur Rettung
des Regionalspitals scheitert klar.
Sie haben den Antrag
mit 29 Ja zu 84 Nein
bei drei Enthaltungen abgelehnt.
Auch für die anderen Regionalspitäler
gab es Rettungsanträge,
auch diese scheiterten deutlich.
Im Moment ist das natürlich
eine grosse Enttäuschung.
Ich glaube, wir hätten
etwas Zukunftsfähiges machen können,
das vielleicht in anderen Kantonen
hätte kopiert werden können.
Jetzt bin ich müde,
aber sehr zufrieden.
Regierungsrat Bruno Damann bringt
die Spitalschliessungen locker durch.
Dass es so klar ausgeht ...
- Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Vor einiger Zeit
wäre das unvorstellbar gewesen.
Da rede ich
als Mediziner aus der Seele,
weil ich überzeugt bin, dass wir
zu viele Spitalbetten haben,
dass wir
grössere Einheiten brauchen,
denn wir müssen schauen, dass wir
gutes Fachpersonal bekommen,
sei es in der Pflege, der Therapie
oder auch Mediziner,
Chefärzte, leitende Ärzte.
Eine grössere Einheit
ist einfach das bessere Umfeld
für diese Menschen.
Die Mitte-Partei CVP
war im Rat gespalten.
Zum Wohl.
Beim Umtrunk danach
scheint sie versöhnt.
(Alle) # ... sei ein Trullala,
Trullala, Trullala,
# dem Spender
sei ein Trullala, Trullala.
Zum Wohl.
Spitäler wie das in Altstätten
schliessen.
und das mitten in einer Pandemie -
ist das wirklich eine gute Idee?
"Ja", sagt der Chef aller St. Galler
Spitäler, Felix Sennhauser.
Wir brauchen
nicht so viele Spitäler,
selbst um eine Pandemie
kompetent bewältigen zu können.
Diese Erkenntnis hatte Sennhauser
bereits in der ersten Corona-Welle.
Er war im Frühling 2020 unterwegs
und schaute sich
die St. Galler Spitäler an.
Sennhauser traf den Chef
der drei Spitäler Grabs,
Altstätten und Walenstadt,
Stefan Lichtensteiger.
Von diesen dreien würden mit
der neuen Strategie zwei geschlossen.
Bleiben würde noch dieses Spital,
das Spital Grabs.
Schön, dass du da bist.
- Geht's gut?
Zuerst die Frage:
Wenn wir die Strategie
bereits umgesetzt hätten, Stefan,
hättet ihr dann auch alles
in diesem Spital bewältigen können?
Wenn man berücksichtigt,
wie Grabs nach der Strategie
ausgebaut werden soll,
hätten wir alles problemlos
hier bewältigen können.
Diese Pandemiephase
hat den Strategieprozess
in einem gewissen Mass bestätigt.
Der effektive Mangel
war nicht bei den Betten,
nicht bei den Beatmungsgeräten,
sondern letztlich beim Personal.
Da war der Engpass.
Um in der Lage zu sein,
16 Beatmungsbetten zu betreiben,
haben wir das Anästhesiepersonal
von Altstätten und Walenstadt
hier in Grabs zentriert und konnten
in Altstätten nicht mehr operieren.
In einer Pandemie müssen Spitäler
möglichst effizient sein.
Man brauche also weniger Spitäler,
dafür grössere.
So könne man mehr Patientinnen
und Patienten behandeln.
Für die Spitalbetreiber hat auch
die zweite, heftigere Corona-Welle
die Schliessungen
nicht infrage gestellt,
sondern erst recht bestätigt.
Im St. Galler Rheintal wird es
also eine Umstrukturierung geben.
Walter Frei
wurden vor wenigen Stunden
die Gallensteine herausoperiert.
Frei fühlt sich wohl
im Spital Altstätten.
Dass es ein altes Gebäude
mit kleinen Zimmern
und einem sehr kleinen Fernseher ist,
stört ihn nicht.
Mir fehlt absolut nichts.
Ich habe ja alles:
Telefon, Fernseher, gutes Zimmer ...
... schöne Aussicht.
Ich bekomme alles, was ich will.
Was will ich mehr?
Einen grösseren Fernseher.
- Einen grösseren Fernseher?
Okay, das wäre vielleicht ...
Aber das geht ja.
Aus meiner Sicht
ist das eine Notlösung.
Walter Frei hat eines der
besseren Zimmer mit WC und Dusche.
Andere Patienten
müssen das WC im Gang benutzen.
Das Spital
müsste viel Geld investieren -
2014 hatte das Stimmvolk
dem noch zugestimmt.
Zurück ins Baselbiet, nach Laufen.
Hier ist das Spital
seit Kurzem geschlossen.
Trotzdem kämpft eine Bürgerbewegung
weiter für das Spital.
In ihren Augen
wurde das Laufental verraten.
Als das Tal vor knapp 30 Jahren
den Kanton wechselte
und von Bern zu Baselland kam,
habe man den Laufentalern den Erhalt
des Spitals schriftlich versprochen.
Josef Cueni hat lange als technischer
Leiter im Spital gearbeitet
und die Spitalgeschichte
dokumentiert.
Hier ist einer.
Was bedeutet Ihnen dieses Archiv?
Diese Unterlagen belegen,
dass uns unsere Politiker
ein Leben lang angelogen haben -
also seit dem Kantonswechsel.
Jetzt sammelt der Verein in Laufen
Geld für eine Klage gegen den Kanton.
Das Bundesgericht
soll ihm recht geben.
Das Spital sei nötig für die Region,
davon sind
viele Laufentaler überzeugt.
Zweimal haben Sie mir
im Spital Laufen das Leben gerettet.
Ich halte zum Spital.
Wir brauchen das Spital.
Die Politiker, die es ablehnen,
sollten mal
in eine solche Situation kommen,
wenn das Spital nicht mehr da ist -
dann müssen sie
ins Bruderholz gehen.
Wenn sie hier vorbeifahren
und etwas passiert
und sie müssen
ins Bruderholz gebracht werden -
vielleicht reicht es gar nicht,
weil das Spital Laufen weg ist.
Das Spital Laufen
war eines von drei Kantonsspitälern.
Das Bruderholzspital und das Spital
im Hauptort Liestal bleiben bestehen.
Die Spitaldichte in der Region
ist hoch:
Es gibt die öffentlichen Spitäler
von Basel-Stadt,
Privatkliniken und das Spital
im solothurnischen Dornach.
Laufen hat
den Wettkampf der Spitäler verloren.
Übrig bleibt ein ambulantes Zentrum.
Das macht vielen Angst.
Das nächste Spital
ist das Bruderholz
oder über den Hügel nach Liestal.
Das ist einfach zu weit weg.
Wenn jemand, der in Roggenburg lebt,
einen Herzinfarkt
oder einen Hirnschlag hat ...
Da zählt jede Minute.
Ich sage Ihnen mal was:
Wenn jemand einen Hirnschlag,
eine Hirnblutung
oder einen Herzstillstand hat,
hat er auf der Fahrt
von hier hinten nach dort vorne
vielleicht noch
eine Chance von 20 %.
Wer in der Nähe der Stadt wohnt,
hat eine Chance von 80 %.
Es geht darum, Menschen am Leben
zu erhalten. Das ist mir wichtig.
Ist die medizinische Versorgung
noch gewährleistet,
wenn ein Regionalspital
geschlossen wird?
Hat man schlechtere Chancen
bei einem Herzinfarkt?
Dauert die Fahrt in der Ambulanz
vom Land ins Zentrumsspital zu lange?
* Drängende Musik *
Unterwegs mit der Ambulanz in Laufen,
wenige Wochen
vor der Schliessung des Spitals.
* Sirene *
Notruf. Verdacht auf Herzinfarkt.
Die Zeit läuft.
(Frau) Ja?
- Guten Tag, Barth ist mein Name.
Die Patientin
ist wach und ansprechbar,
doch das könnte sich
plötzlich ändern.
Für die Rettungssanitäter ist klar:
Sie könnte in einer
lebensbedrohlichen Situation sein
und muss genauer untersucht werden -
in der Ambulanz.
Diese ist
nicht bloss Transportmittel,
sondern quasi
eine fahrende Notaufnahme.
Im Moment denke ich,
ein ACS ist möglich.
Hier erstellen die Sanitäter
ein genaues EKG
und sammeln Daten
über den Zustand der Patientin.
16,0. Okay.- Also können wir
etwas Flüssigkeit geben?
Ich denke, das tun wir sowieso.
Atemfrequenz 35,
das ist einfach sehr hoch.
Das gefällt mir nicht so sehr.
Die Daten der Patientin
schicken die Rettungssanitäter
zur Spezialistin
im Kantonsspital Liestal.
Hallo, hier ist Nathanael
vom Rettungsdienst Laufen.
Ich habe eine Patientin bei mir.
Ich habe ihr EKG telemetriert.
Sie besprechen das weitere Vorgehen
und die Medikamente.
Ja. Ich würde jetzt
5'000 Einheiten Heparin ...
Okay.
71, äh, 49.
Die Therapie beginnt in der
stehenden Ambulanz vor der Haustür.
Ich gebe ihr 4 l Sauerstoff, v.a.
auch bei dieser Atemfrequenz von 36.
Das ist eine Ansage.
Und dann gehen wir mit Verdacht
auf Lungenembolie nach Liestal.
Und das zeitdringlich,
wenn du damit einverstanden bist.
Mit Sondersignal, ja.
- Genau.
Die Kardiologin vermutet einen
Herzinfarkt oder eine Lungenembolie.
Im Moment passt alles
eher zur Lungenembolie.
Haben Sie mitbekommen,
was wir vermuten?
Wir glauben, dass Sie ein kleines
Blutgerinnsel in der Lunge haben.
Ich gebe Ihnen jetzt
ziemlich viel Blutverdünner,
damit das Gerinnsel
nicht grösser wird,
das wir in der Lunge vermuten.
(Funk) Verstanden, antworten.
Verstanden.
Wir fahren mit Sondersignal
nach Liestal, Notfallstation.
Ja, verstanden.
* Sirene *
Während der Fahrt
wird die Patientin überwacht.
Sie atmet weiterhin
aussergewöhnlich schnell.
Das ist ein Zeichen dafür,
dass der Körper ein Problem hat.
Er kompensiert etwas,
sei das etwas an der Lunge
oder am Herzen.
Aber das ist für uns
wirklich ein Indiz,
dass etwas nicht in Ordnung ist.
Die Patientin aus Laufen muss also
so schnell wie möglich ins Spital.
Für die Rettungssanitäter ist klar:
Es hat keinen Sinn,
ins nahe Spital Laufen zu fahren.
Es muss das weiter entfernte
Spital Liestal sein.
In Liestal
haben wir die Möglichkeit,
sofort intervenieren zu können,
falls es etwas am Herzen ist.
Wir könnten auch ein Gerinnsel,
wenn eines in der Lunge wäre,
lysieren, also auflösen.
Diese Möglichkeiten haben wir
im Kantonsspital in Laufen nicht.
Die Zeit drängt
auf der Fahrt ins Spital.
Noch ist die Patientin stabil,
aber ihr Zustand könnte sich
jederzeit verschlechtern.
Von Laufen bis ins Spital Liestal
sind es rund 30 km -
knappe 30 Min. Fahrt.
... Ihre Beine etwas spreizen?
Dann kann ich
die Sauerstoffflasche ...
Wie viele Liter möchtest du haben?
- Vier.
Knapp 1 Std. nachdem der Alarm
bei den Sanitätern eingegangen ist,
kommt die Patientin
im Kantonsspital Liestal an.
* Sie murmelt etwas. *
Ja, nicht?
(Patientin) Ich weiss es nicht.
- Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Sie ist hier im richtigen Spital.
Sie ist in guten Händen.
Die Diagnostik läuft.
Sie untersuchen jetzt
in alle Richtungen,
was genau sie hat.
Ich glaube, vor Ort
hätten wir nicht mehr tun können.
Wir konnten ihr
die maximale Versorgung bieten.
Die Diagnose wird zeigen:
Es war ein Herzinfarkt.
Hier im Kantonsspital Liestal
wurde die 71-Jährige operiert.
Sie erhielt einen sog. Stent.
Das können nicht alle Spitäler,
sondern nur Spitäler
mit einem Herzkatheterlabor.
Das Kantonsspital Liestal
betreibt eines
von über 30 Labors in der Schweiz.
Diese sind eingerichtet, um via
Katheter Untersuchungen zu machen
und verschlossene Blutgefässe
zu öffnen.
Alltag für den leitenden Arzt
Gregor Leibundgut.
Jeder Herzinfarktpatient müsse direkt
in ein solches Labor gebracht werden.
Und das ist dann auch
nicht das eigene Spital
oder das befreundete Spital,
sondern dasjenige,
in dem der Patient die Behandlung
in kürzester Zeit bekommen kann.
Die Behandlung
in solchen Herzkatheterlabors
hat die Sterblichkeit
bei Herzinfarkten
in den letzten 20 Jahren gesenkt.
Früher wurde zuerst medikamentös
versucht, das Gerinnsel zu lösen.
Heute wird beim Herzinfarkt
schneller operiert.
Müssten solche Operationen
nicht auch in Laufen möglich sein,
um die Sterblichkeit zu senken?
Für eine professionelle Behandlung
braucht man ein
voll ausgerüstetes Katheterlabor,
und das
beinhaltet auch das Personal.
Das kann sich nicht jedes Dorf
und jedes Städtchen leisten.
Das ist finanziell nicht tragbar,
und v.a.
finden Sie auch das Personal nicht.
Selbst wenn man einen Gönner hätte,
könnte man nicht in jedem Dorf
qualifiziertes Personal
organisieren.
Und somit muss man schauen,
was eine sichere Distanz ist,
sodass man einen Patienten
ohne grösseren Schaden
ins nächste Zentrum bringen kann.
Von Laufen nach Liestal
oder an die Universität in Basel,
mit der wir nachts zusammenarbeiten,
ist eine klar vertretbare Distanz.
Konzentration und Spezialisierung
sind das Gebot der Stunde.
Was passiert, wenn dieser Umbruch
konsequent weitergedacht wird?
Heute stehen über 200 Spitäler
und Kliniken in der Schweiz.
Fast nirgends auf der Welt
ist die Spitaldichte so hoch.
Doch wie viele Spitäler
brauchen wir wirklich?
Spezialisten der Beratungsfirma PwC
haben ein Szenario berechnet.
Wir nutzten
ein umfangreiches Modell,
das mit Daten aller stationären
Fälle in der Schweiz unterlegt war -
jeder Patient, der in einem Spital
übernachtet hatte,
war anonym in dieser Datenbank.
Damit simulierten wir,
wo diese Spitäler sein müssten.
Das waren z.T. durchaus Standorte,
die einen guten Autobahnanschluss
und einen guten Bahnhof haben,
wo aber heute
noch kein Spital steht.
Wir fragten das Modell quasi,
wie viele Spitäler wir brauchen,
um eine gute Versorgung zu haben.
Und das war die Zahl,
die dabei herauskam.
Das Resultat:
Statt über 200
wären nur noch 50 Spitäler nötig.
So würden immer noch
90 % der Schweizer Bevölkerung
innerhalb von 30 Min.
ein Spital erreichen.
Man würde Milliarden an
Investitionen in Neubauten sparen.
die medizinische Qualität
würde tendenziell besser,
weil man in diesen Zentren
das medizinische Fachpersonal
bündeln könnte,
Und man würde auch Geld
im laufenden Betrieb sparen,
weil die Infrastruktur,
diese rund 50 Spitäler,
auch nachts und am Wochenende
besser ausgelastet wären
als die Vielzahl an Spitälern heute.
Das Kantonsparlament
hat die Schliessung der Spitäler
definitiv beschlossen.
Die Rheintaler
haben den Entscheid akzeptiert,
ohne das Referendum zu ergreifen.
Ich stelle fest, dass immer öfter
betriebswirtschaftliche Kennzahlen
verwendet werden,
um politische Entscheide zu fällen.
So auch hier.
Es wurde rein
betriebswirtschaftlich betrachtet.
Ich hoffe natürlich
auf eine Trendumkehr,
sonst gewinnen immer
die grossen Zentren,
weil die
betriebswirtschaftlichen Kennzahlen
dort normalerweise besser ausfallen.
Die Gefahr ist, dass die Städte
immer stärker werden,
dass es auf dem Land
letztlich unattraktiver wird.
Dann kann man hier noch schlafen und
in schöner Natur spazieren gehen,
Aber wir brauchen selbstverständlich
auch ein gewisses Angebot
in den ländlicheren Regionen.
Dieses Angebot
müssen wir aufrechterhalten,
sonst verlieren wir
an Attraktivität.
Dazu gehört ein Spital?
In einer Region
wie dem St. Galler Rheintal
mit über 70'000 Einwohnern schon,
meiner Meinung nach.
Altstätten hat
den Wettkampf der Spitäler verloren.
Weiter oben im Rheintal
wird zur gleichen Zeit gefeiert.
Das Spital Grabs bleibt bestehen
und wurde bereits ausgebaut.
Der erste Patient kommt.
Der erste Patient
wird in den Neubau verlegt,
begleitet von den lokalen Medien.
Der Spitaldirektor
begrüsst den Patienten persönlich.
Herr Frey, herzlich willkommen.
Sie sind der erste Patient
im neuen Spital.
Ich heisse Sie im Namen
der Geschäftsleitung willkommen.
Wir führen Sie rein.
Die Spitalbetreiber
wollen das Bild vermitteln,
die neue Spitalstrategie
sei keine reine Abbaumassnahme,
es werde investiert
in Spitäler der Zukunft.
Ich stelle die Blumen gleich in
die Vase - sie steht schon bereit.
Wir haben maximal noch Zweierzimmer.
Früher hatten wir Mehrbettzimmer.
Aus Mitarbeitersicht
schufen wir im Neubau die Voraus-
setzungen für optimale Prozesse.
Wir haben gute Stationsgrössen.
So können wir
unsere Patientinnen und Patienten
qualitativ wirklich gut
behandeln und betreuen.
Aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht
sind die Prozesse so abgestimmt,
dass man das zu vernünftigen Kosten
machen kann.
Die Spitallandschaft im Umbruch.
Spitäler wollen Kosten sparen
sowie zeitgemässe Zimmer
und bessere Qualität bieten.
Doch nicht jedes Spital
wird diesen Wettkampf überleben.
In Laufen endet die
knapp 150-jährige Spitalgeschichte.
Das Kantonsspital Baselland
hat an seinen drei Standorten
in den letzten Jahren
über 100 Stellen abgebaut.
Spitaldirektor Norbert Schnitzler
am Umzugstag im September 2020
im leeren Spital.
Gähnende Leere.
Musste man dieses Spital
jetzt wirklich schliessen?
Für den Betrieb
ist ja eigentlich alles da.
Man kann alles irgendwie erzwingen.
Man könnte auch erzwingen,
dass man das aufrechterhalten will.
Aber dann müssten wir
zum Kanton gehen und sagen:
"Aus regionalpolitischen Gründen
soll das aufrechterhalten werden."
Und dann ist das Millionendefizit,
das wir hier jedes Jahr hatten,
einfach auf der Rechnung des Kantons
und damit auf der Rechnung
aller Steuerzahler/-innen.
Die letzte Patientin muss
vom Spital Laufen Abschied nehmen.
Also. Es wäre so weit.
Ja, ich bin schon ungeduldig.
- Sind Sie? Ja, das glaube ich.
Frau Straumann,
ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute.
Vielen Dank.
- Passen Sie auf sich auf.
Also, dann gehen wir.
Gut.
Kommt vielleicht eine von euch mit?
So.
Sie sind die Letzte, die rausfährt.
Die anderen sind schon draussen?
- Ja.
* Langsame, schwere Musik *
So, das letzte Mal in den Lift.
Alles ist das letzte Mal.
Auszug aus Ägypten.
Lucie Straumann
wird sich im Bruderholzspital
weiter von Ihrer Fraktur erholen.
Wie ist es für Sie,
die letzte Patientin zu sein?
Leider.
Ich wünschte, es gäbe mehr.
Nicht,
dass ich mir Patienten wünsche,
aber für Laufen tut es mir leid.
Die Mitarbeitenden
werden sich am anderen Standort
um die Patientinnen
und Patienten kümmern.
Dann sehen wir uns
im Bruderholz wieder.
* Lautes Surren *
Geht es so? Gute Fahrt.
- Danke.
Also,
ich verabschiede mich schon mal.
Auf Wiedersehen. Wir sehen uns
spätestens am Donnerstag.
Machen Sie's gut.
Danke.
- Kommen Sie gut an.
Zu wissen, dass es
mit dem Spital zu Ende ist ...
Es ist nicht wegen der Patienten -
die sehe ich ja wieder.
Aber zu wissen,
dass das letzte Mal war,
dass jemand hier
stationär gelegen hat ...
Was macht das mit Ihnen?
Nachdenklich
für die Zukunft und die Leute.
Nicht, Mädels?
Auch sie sind traurig, nicht?
- Ja.
Ja, aber es ist halt so.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Roger Schmid, Daniel McMinn - 2021